this chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook John good morning I'm gonna start
with the president he's been saying how
he's been getting tested daily obviously
that's an option that he has right now
but is that enough is it good enough the
fact that he's getting tested daily it's
something that the rest of us don't have
that option for well the problem is is
he possibly infecting others and here's
the two things you need to know
one is the incubation period is 2 to 14
days and the other is people can have no
symptoms a couple of days before they
actually get the symptoms and be
shedding virus and infecting others so
let's say five days ago I get exposed
and I'm actually infected with the virus
right and then I'm tested every day I
feel perfectly fine I'm not shedding
virus yet and so four days ago three
days ago two days ago one day ago I'm
tested and negative but after I'm tested
yesterday I suddenly become infectious
it starts to blossom at that point for
the rest of the day I can be infecting
other people until the next day when I
finally get tested and it turns out to
be positive and then maybe I'll get
symptoms a day or two later or maybe I
won't get symptoms so that's the problem
is that people can get the daily testing
it may be saying okay they're not
infected that day but there's this
window where they could possibly be
infecting others along those lines as I
think about it we're starting to open up
the country and people are getting out
there they might even be going out and
seeing more people remind us a little
bit about some of the social distancing
guidelines especially as it comes to
masks and people that you haven't seen
for a while yeah it's so tempting to
just say I'm out there it's gonna be
back to normal it's not back to normal
and even though you can't see this virus
it's still there so we're saying at
least six feet away from people wearing
the face masks it's so important to wash
your hands for 20 seconds with soap and
water and then here's here's the tough
thing is it's so hard to not touch your
face with your hands there was a study
of Australian medical students they
secretly videotaped they touch their
face 23 times an hour so you have to
still understand that the virus is there
and even though people are starting to
have spring
you still have to do all this all the
things that everybody told you to do
Michelle Miller now here we know that
many people with the virus are
asymptomatic and that's where the
antibody tests come into play so let's
say you get tested and find out
you carry corona virus antibodies what
should you do then you do absolutely
nothing differently because here's the
problem Michelle even if you have
antibodies we still don't know the
billion dollar question which is are you
protected from getting reinfected so you
can't have a false sense of security and
say oh I've got the antibodies I can do
anything I don't have to do any of these
measures the CDC is all over this
they're saying look if you do get the
antibody test and you test positive you
still have to do all the social
distancing I don't like social its
physical distancing right we're socially
where we're pulling we're hugging each
other more than ever but the physical
distancing all the measures we talked
about hand-washing coughing into the
crook of your arm so don't have any
sense of false security and elbow
bumping but don't because you're not six
feet apart dr. Jon LaPook we thank you
so much well it's about five after the
hour now here's a look at the weather
for